in the desperation and deprivation of
war it is possible to find joy in the
smallest things for ten-year-old Abdul
Rahman and his 12 year old sister regard
that joy is the bicycle they share
for months now there's has been a life
on the move
alive fleeing bombing and death a life
with an eye always on the skies looking
and listening for what is coming next
they and their bike somehow so far
survival unit lalala heck move a dynamo
Vedic TV - whistling Allah is mahavakya
comments are irrelevant original analogy
with a more dynamic way Serena I'm Annie
Annie so bacterial pneumonia banana
magnessen afikomen saba saboteur de
jakke ma vie en casa firma firma pega so
fakie sub 2 Hecky
fear keeps potato [ __ ] I have a
parable worked in the digital age a
refugee have to tear over never over
narrow honor ACMA not all over the road
they are the waves of the innocent the
unknowing for the truth is they have a
long and dangerous road in front of them
often it is best to travel by night out
of sight of those who would do them harm
and every stop even in the darkness has
its small mercies after several hours
they arrive at the camp where their
cousins have already taken refuge regard
and Abdulrahman have made this journey
with their uncle their mother and father
have stayed behind in the last place
they called home they pray they will
come in the next few days in the tent
they play a game to take their minds off
war who knows where these young feet
will have to carry them next cost in sky
news on the syria-turkey border